[Music]
we're super excited today to have an Cod
joining us from Boston University and is
the Dean of Arts and Sciences at Boston
University she's also a professor of
philosophy before that she was at the
University of Kansas where I was living
behind me in the alley she was not
living in the alley she was living
across the alley in a lovely home
I lovely home yes I raised her since she
was a whippersnapper and has done and
ann is a very interesting person for
this lab because she has a undergraduate
degree in mathematics
she's a philosopher she wrote her
dissertation on game theory she studies
feminism she studies oppression and she
has a lot of overlaps with a lot of
different interests that a lot of us
have so I thought it would be delightful
to have her come by and I will let you
go ahead
she's cratons of accomplishments lots of
books lots of praise all of that stuff
but thank you so much Nancy it's it's
such a privilege to get to come here and
to speak with you and thank you for
allowing a philosopher to come in and
and talk about you know the metaphysics
of the self up so the I I don't think
that's what Nancy had initially imagined
that I would speak about but I told her
this is actually the the most recent
research paper that I've been working on
so she said well if you're passionate
about it then go for it so so I am
promising some implications of my work
for something that I think maybe many of
you are interested in so basically let
me just get started and let me provide
some context of why I'm thinking about
self ownership and how this could play a
role in in the kinds of things that many
of you think about so if you think about
it there's a very basic moral or
political question that moral and
political philosophers should try to
answer and that is something like what
do persons have a right to do and to say
and what can society
or other individuals force us to do on
pain of some social sanction whether
that's you know from just disapproval
all the way to incarceration or worse
okay so any kind of social sanction so
what do we have a right to do and what
can society force us to do and basically
philosophers method the typical
philosophy philosophers method is to
establish some basic concepts some basic
principles go to sort of first
principles that can then ground a theory
that can answer the questions okay so
you know our our theory is usually built
up with some kind of argument from
example or analogy or counter example
and it really it's pretty basic and so
it's not usually empirical although as
we were talking about at lunch today
sometimes philosophers do a little bit
of experimental work but I'm afraid I'm
not one of those philosophers so it's
it's you know basic argumentation so
that's the kind of methodology I'm going
to use so self ownership is one of these
basic concepts in particular it's a
basic concept for libertarianism so
libertarianism I'm going to be speaking
of libertarianism not very much but a
little bit today as a political
philosophy and not necessarily in the
sort of Rand Paul you know contemporary
political empirically practically
political world okay I'm going to be
talking about insofar as I do talk about
libertarianism I'm going to be talking
about the basic political philosophy so
what what libertarians do with self
ownership as they say that they they
posit this idea and they don't usually
examine it very carefully but they posit
the idea that each of us owns ourselves
and they especially concentrate on this
idea of ownership and that brings a lot
of
moral political weight with it and it's
because ownership rights are taken to be
very stringent rights their rights to
use or possess or exclude others from
using rights to dispose of or transfer
some kind of a thing so if I own my
toothbrush I can use it I possess it I
can exclude youth from using it I hope I
can throw it away when I want to and if
I want to give it away I can give it
away ok so there's something about you
know we think about ownership as as
having those kinds of claims now of
course you can take those apart we can
you can make up different kinds of
ownership rights legally you can take
all of those pieces apart but basically
that this is why libertarians are you
are interested in this idea of
self-ownership is because it gives us a
very solid significant stringent claim
over our own bodies and then by
extension over the things that our
bodies do and in particular the ways
that we gain the right to property so
libertarians well if you think about
even old liberals classical liberals
like John Locke who argued that from the
ownership of ourselves when we work on
some unknown nature maybe we pluck an
apple from an apple tree that nobody
owns we come to own that through our
labor we come to own the Apple that we
have now labored on by an extension of
our own bodies anyway that's is I'm not
really going to talk much about that I'm
just trying to motivate the idea that
self ownership provides especially for
the libertarian this important stringent
right over our bodies and then over our
things and libertarians appeal to this
idea to say first of all that for each
of us our bodies or ourselves whatever a
self is in addition to a body but
over our bodies we cannot be used or
possessed without our consent and you
know that's pretty important right right
that's one thing and another is that our
duties to help others or to do things
for others can only arise from our
voluntary consent so libertarians are
very keen to say that you cannot force
me to help you unless I consent to some
kind of contractual arrangement with you
okay so so that's how you get this sort
of idea of libertarianism that's you
know against taxation that's four very
stringent property rights and builds
this kind of Cocoon if you will around
the individual okay and I'm
characterizing a little bits of our
character so if you're a libertarian
please feel free to to attack that
caricature but I'm trying to do it for
for the sake of simplicity and clarity
and it's overly simplistic perhaps okay
so that's the idea of self-ownership as
the libertarian looks at it and the
ideal itself is I think has two very
important characteristics it's one very
individualistic so the self is to be
fully identified with the individual on
some theories
that's the individual body and and and
on other theories well you don't have to
just identify the self with the body it
could be with the rational individual
that's inside of me or a rational
individual okay the thing that is the
agent in game theory or something like
that or in decision theory and the other
aspect of it is that it's an atomistic
theory so individuals are separable from
the external world at least in principle
okay so the people who populate a
libertarian theory
are these self-contained self-sufficient
individual rational individuals okay so
that might be familiar to some of you
economists and the theory you know the
basically the theory of Homo economicus
or something like that it's not not that
different from that so what I'm going to
do in my argument today is I'm going to
deny both of these aspects of
self-ownership and argue that a self
owner so a entity that can own itself
and that can be the foundation of a
political or moral theory is actually
necessarily connected to other self
owners so is not atomistic but connected
within a network of norms and social
practices and the social practices of
guiding each other according to social
norms so that that guidance and being
guided by and guiding others according
to norms rules practices things that
judgments of better and worse that kind
of thing are really really important to
making us the kind of things we are
namely self owners that can be the
foundation of a moral and political
philosophy so are you with me that's the
basic context here that we're talking
about okay so I want to draw a sharp
distr a careful distinction between
descriptive and normative individualism
so I take myself to be a kind of liberal
in a large broad sense of liberal in the
sense of what I would say is normative
individualism that is I take the human
self whatever it is to be of ultimate
intrinsic moral value okay so the whole
point to me of doing political and moral
philosophy is to in some sense give a
theory that protects that individual
moral self
we are of ultimate value and descriptive
individual individualism by contrast is
just claims that the human self can be
described and explained by references
reference to forces and causes that act
only on the individual and not having to
refer to any irreducibly social facts so
I think that descriptive individualism
is false but normative individualism is
true I think that the atomistic self
owner of libertarianism is a descriptive
individualist theory it's also
normatively individualist okay but I
deny the descriptive part I don't deny
the normative part so as I say
liberalism rests on normative
individualism but it need not embrace
the descriptive one and I think that
libertarianism is a form of liberalism
that embraces both descriptive and
normative individualism and just to give
you a contrast and I'm not going to be
talking about this view at all but
communitarianism denies normative
individualism as well as well as
descriptive individualism okay
yes
I don't think that's impossible and
that's my view but I think that's a kind
of liberalism but that's a good really
good question okay so so here's here's
where I think this the two might I mean
I'd have to hear more about what you
mean by communitarianism but where they
might split apart yeah well where they
might split apart is suppose you think
that we should sacrifice individuals for
the sake of preservation of some kind of
community so for instance not allow a
right of exit from a community there are
communities that don't allow individuals
to exit on without very very significant
costs that I would say is kind of a
denial of right of exit and to me that's
anti-liberal okay but then you might say
well okay but then that's denying
normative individualism so I think I
think you can't be a normative
individualist a communitarian okay so
here's the thesis that I'm going to
defend I'm going to argue that self
owners can't be the atomistic
individuals portrayed by the concept of
libertarian self ownership they're
essentially constituted by their
connections with other cells so this
word essentially is you know obviously a
pretty important word for philosopher
and means I'm going to start talking
metaphysics here because it's got to be
really that's a strong claim you know
essential it's really basic so I'm
giving a metaphysical arguments because
I think that's a more stringent argument
than a merely causal one
so lots of libertarians will say to me
oh of course we think that you know
infants have to be cared for by their
parents and people need all kinds of
care and so causally yes we're all
dependent on each other sure but
essentially we are separable individuals
and so that's why I think I have to go
to this metaphysical point claim or
metaphysical plane if you will so join
me in this this quest on this
metaphysical plane to to make to really
make the argument right in the end if
you all want to say or some of you want
to say well really why do we care about
the metaphysics in some sense I'll say
yeah I understand where you're coming
from because what's really important
ultimately is the politics right and
what we actually hold each other
accountable for but my view is that if
you want to defeat the argument the best
rational argument of the libertarian you
have to go to this metaphysical plane
yes I don't think it is dependent on
that
however if if there's not a connection
among those cells then it's hard to say
what the right self would have of it
changes over time so that I think there
has to be some kind of continuity so I
would obscure subscribe to a
psychological continuity thesis about
personal identity if if that's I mean
that's basically the philosophical
problem I think that you're referring to
but within that of course if you
psychological continuity is consistent
with a lot of change over time right
just as long as there's kind of a memory
or a connection from one moment to the
next okay
okay so here's just to say a little bit
more about why this has got to be a
metaphysical argument and not a causal
one or to say a little bit more about
what that means so I think you can
separate out what what I would call the
causal Oriya the origins of any given
self so you know I was born on a certain
day to a certain pair of parents with a
certain set of you know genetic
components nurtured by you know the food
that they gave me the mman taught by the
words that they spoke to me the various
stimulants that they presented to me and
then over time as I became a child and
started playing with peers and so forth
there were further causal interactions
that have formed me up to the point
where I am the person that I am so those
are all I think causal origins of this
self right the metaphysical origins of a
self though are something a little bit
different and that is what are the
necessary kin this is the question what
is what are the necessary conditions for
something to be a self that is a self
owner okay so that's a very much more
basic and conceptual question than the
causal question about of how did I get
to be the self that I am today okay or
even or even the causal the generic
causal question of how do people
generally grow up to be the adult human
beings that they are so you can ask that
causal question in those two separate
ways a very particular way in a more
generic way that has to do with sort of
the causal laws right and by causal I
mean you know not just physical but oops
but also mental and social causes so the
things that I think right now the self
you know having these thoughts about
metaphysics and so forth right now as I
speak has social causes and mental
causes so I've had previous thoughts
about about philosophy about well
whatever all of those things that if you
have made me thinking think the things
that I think right now I guess yes I am
deterministic right that's just to say
the self is deterministic and there are
social causes so there are all kinds of
different Sciences that would play a
nice role in explaining how human beings
come to be the the things that they are
today in this culture with these
thoughts with these tendencies but
metaphysical origins has to do with what
is a self owner how does it come to be
the thing that it is so if you're
thinking about moral and political
philosophy and what you want to do is is
have a theory that holds regardless of
the particularity of how the being came
into existence causally and philosophers
tend to want to do that because we want
to have a moral and political philosophy
that would work for robots or for
entities on a distant exoplanet right
doesn't matter provided that they are
the kinds of things that are self owners
this moral and political theory should
fit for them ok ok so it so so the
assumptions I'm making about what a self
owner is or has to do has to be in order
to be the grounding for of social and
political philosophy or for moral and
political philosophy is that those self
owners have to be intrinsically valuable
they have to be capable of making and
respecting that shouldn't be respective
respecting ownership claims so in other
words what is it to be an owner well
it's to be able to make a claim on
something so that's a basic assumption
what is it to be no you know if we want
normative individualism to hold well has
to be intrinsically valuable and not
valuable just because of the advantages
it brings to somebody it's something
else right it has to be valuable in
itself and the part about respecting
ownership claims and their I think if
it's going to be an entity that's a
grounding for a moral and political
philosophy then it has to be capable of
basically acting morally so it has to be
able to respect the claims of others
just capable of that might turn out to
be an immoral version of one of these
beings but at least it's capable of
understanding and respecting us so as I
say though the metaphysical question
doesn't assume that self owners are
necessarily human or even biological or
that they're embodied and an analogy to
this kind of metaphysical question I'm
asking is and you know think about chess
pieces and chess boards you could have a
chess set of chess chess pieces that are
made out of ivory and you could have a
wooden board or you could have a digital
representation of chess pieces and the
rules of chess and chess boards right
and both of them are equally chess
pieces and chess boards it doesn't
matter so what makes them that is the
set of rules that you're applying to the
to the movements of the chess pieces
okay so yes
that would not be well not human might
be some other social primates that BZ
but I I'm not sure of that but because
I'm not a biological anthropologist but
I bet you know maybe baboons are like
this I don't know they could respect
biological well you could imagine a
virtual beings in fact that would count
it's not embodied - all right algorithms
there might be you know how right it
could be a self owner that would I I
don't think that how could be a
connected self owner
well maybe how is connected to his to
the people that he lived among Dave
right right maybe between them yeah what
but that's what I'm trying to leave open
the possibility of a virtual being and
and the idea that there might be an
artificial intelligence where you would
say it would be it would be immoral to
unplug it or to kill it because it's
intrinsically valuable why because it's
capable of the same capabilities of
self-ownership that we are I don't think
it exists yet but in our dreams right ok
ok good so this is just a little you
know
representation of these sort of
hierarchies so so we you know they're
actually existing cell phone errs are a
subset of the possible physically
possible ones but the metaphysically
possible ones are even beyond a bigger
set right I think that's just ok so here
we go here's the argument ok now I need
my notes ok so the first premise is just
to say that if if the self owners are to
be foundational for moral and political
philosophy then they're going to have to
have intrinsic moral
and they have to have the ability to
participate in some community or polity
it's just from the meaning of moral
theory or political philosophy really
okay if they're not valuable then then
they're not sort of the subject of a
moral theory okay if they're valuable I
should draw the distinction between
intrinsic and instrumental value just
I'm assuming that so something that's
intrinsically valuable is valuable in
and of itself right without considering
anything else something that's merely
instrumentally valuable is valuable
because it's valuable to something that
is intrinsically valuable all right so
so the subjects of moral and political
theory I believe have to be I don't
think this is controversial have to be
intrinsically valuable and what is it to
participate in a in a community or a
polity well minimally I think it means
that you're able to reflect on norms
rules or something more informal rules
that are given to you externally and
guide your actions according to them so
for instance to learn that it's it's bad
or wrong to do X and it's good or right
to do Y or you know just some basic
rules and and some basic normative
claims something is is apt appropriate
good right preferable any of those kind
of judgments okay and then even more
fully than that more fulsomely is to be
able to guide others actions minimally
you have to be able to guide your own
actions according to these rules but
even better real participation in a
polity or community is that you are not
just the subject but you're the agent
as well okay and that means I think in
order to be able to do that reflection
on norms and guiding one's actions
according to those norms one has to have
mental states and intentions beliefs
desires okay so one has to be able to
see what the norm is see what will
consider an action and judge whether
that action fits the norm or doesn't and
likewise judge about other's actions do
they fit according to the norm or not
okay and right now I'm using norm in a
in a very descriptive way in the sense
that it might be a bad norm right but
it's it's a norm agreed upon by some
community okay some group right I'm just
trying to get as long as you can see
that you violated a norm then you're
participating in this very basic sense
acknowledgement yeah at minimum and I'm
just trying to get the minimum
qualifications for something to be a
self owner again because I'm trying to
get this metaphysical very broad view
and include everything in that we
possibly can and the reason for that is
because suppose I make a very broad you
know all of these things could be self
owners but the one thing that can't are
the atomistic individuals of libertarian
theory all right that's you know kind of
the structure of my argument okay so
have to have mental states intentions
beliefs desires so that they can take in
norms reflect on norms or rules and what
is it to be an owner so well minimally
again that's to have a claim over a
thing that is owned and a claim against
others over others
excluding exclusively claiming it and an
ability make use of or possess it again
this is just from sort of the very
definition of ownership what it is to
own something okay so I get it so what I
am saying though is that one has to be
able to actively make a claim and that
again is bringing in intentions and
beliefs and desires okay so so I'm
concluding from those last two premises
about ownership and participation that a
self owner must be a thing that intends
and acts and that can take and respond
to norms and that's just what in other
words is a moral person so philosophers
always talk about what is a person and
for you know there's kind of a high bar
for personhood it's not just having the
right number of chromosomes or roughly
the right number of chromosomes it's
actually having this ability to intend
an act and take and respond to norms so
a self owner has to be a moral person
well now that that sort of I guess key
premise is to say is six which is to say
that what makes a self existence as this
moral person as this thing that can
think intend and act is that it's
embedded in a normative web of
meaningfulness so why is that well if
I'm going to have an intention I intend
to do X or I intend some sort of
meaningful thing it has to be to have a
meaning for me but meaning then
immediately I think brings in language
and language is essentially social one
individual atomistic individual cannot
come up with a language a language is
essentially social and so I believe that
once we taught our start starting to
talk about things as having intention
beliefs and desires we've already
brought in the social namely language
but there are lots of other norms that
also make our world meaningful so our
judgments of better and worse apt and in
apt good and bad also color the whole
world that we live in so we never see
anything as you know green there chair
right we see it as oh it's a certain
kind of green it's a it's a chair that
you can sit in but you wouldn't want to
lie down in it you know there are all
these judgements that immediately come
with our perception we never perceive
things purely as some kind of data but
always we perceive it as something and
that I believe brings in norms and and
language and if that's the case so that
is the sort of crux of the argument for
me if that's the case then we are
essentially connected in this web of
social norms we're essentially socially
connected do you want to ask a question
understands some of the norms but not
all the norms or respect yeah I haven't
even gotten to that point but and and I
would say jumping ahead a little bit
there are many norms in any given
community that are bad norms and should
be floated there are others that are
optional right its normative for women
to paint their fingernails but it's
optional right it's so there are these
things that maybe is our general
judgments of better and worse in a
community that you know you don't need
to right ah right I think if you can
recognize one you count as one of these
intrinsically valuable self owners oh
yeah right even going against it right
right yeah that's when if you can't you
I mean there is no probably you know
second person who would be the county
side well I mean you know somebody who
has become comatose and will never
regain consciousness again will count as
some as not a self owner on this doesn't
mean you can do whatever you want to to
anything that's not a self owner I'm not
saying that therefore we can cut down
all the trees in the world because
they're not self owners I don't want to
say that but I'm simply trying to make
this claim that anything that we're
going to ground a moral or political
philosophy on has to be something that
can recognize and guide itself according
to norms yeah
that feels like it feels like the
concept of the self
oh now you're saying that needs to be
practical for moral philosophy and
therefore it has to be grounded in
notion of participation and then
participation has no-one was enormous
great all right connection meaningful is
etc should I take away that this is not
a useful concept it's not even concept
is that right yeah I think the idea that
a self owner could be separable from all
other possible self owners like there
could be one in the history of you know
the Big Bang happens then there's one
cell phone or Robinson Crusoe let's call
him he's out there and you know that's
impossible so that's an impossible
metaphysically impossible because he
could never have a language he could
never have norms to guide himself
according to there's also the there also
the fact that well who's he going to
make claims against but that's not the
the point that I'm making right like
yeah I mean he might make claims against
this fine asteroid that's going by or
something yes yeah yes so I think that
once once you've acquired norms and you
remember them and you think crap I miss
my family but they would have wanted me
to go on or you know that's already a
normative way of guiding your actions so
you've internalized these norms I think
we can internalize them and then you
know be all alone in the world now if
you then get hit by the asteroid and you
have amnesia and you remember no norms
and no language and you're no longer a
self owner but yeah so the Robinson
Crusoe story which is often brought up
by libertarians as an example of the
ideal ideal man
right is to me it's it's it's loaded
already with all of the norms that he
was you know so didn't he keep a diary
and stuff I mean he was very much trying
to live like a proper Englishman you
know that's a very normative framework
to be living with him okay so so this
normative web I think is constitutive of
philosophers love to use that term
constitutive of selfhood and this is
just to reiterate the main points of my
central argument and that is to be a
person is to be a mesh in a web of
social relations the normative web that
we are in meshed in is this emergent
normative framework that we collectively
create through our individual behavior
in social interactions right so but our
individual behavior then creates norms
nobody set out to probably - I don't
know create some silly norm that there
exists today in fashion or something but
somebody tried something out and all of
a sudden other people started copying
and pretty-pretty sumit Kim became a
normative way of dressing or acting or
something like that so to use a Haida
garyun phrase which I rarely will do but
this is my favorite one social
institutions are always already there
okay so we are dropped into as
individuals in fact we're sort of
dropped into this normative world that
we find and that shapes us inevitably
yeah there's a kind of an allusion to
something that will or van orman quine
wrote but yeah I don't know maybe that's
it the web of relations mmm-hmm I'm not
sure how much I've loaded into that
except that I think that you have to
think of physical individuals as nodes
in a network or a web and and that
that's a significant
so both the connections and the though
nodes are important so I don't know
that's probably not a very good answer
to why I thought it was cool the picture
was cool anything that would be
connective tissue a network is the other
metaphor so the so you know my
conclusion the normative web including
linguistic norms that connect
individuals who are capable of moral
personhood and without which there could
be no moral persons it has to be itself
intrinsically valuable so it's not just
the individuals but all of our
connectedness so this is a relational
accounts of our relations with each
other are also intrinsically valuable
not just the individual node yes
if you have a relationship with a let's
say with the environment with nature
like you don't think about the
indigenous community and their sense of
society yeah so I am kind of subversive
if I didn't my norms so the thing is
that the tree can't be a cellphone Iran
might view ok doesn't mean that the tree
isn't valuable but on my view it would
have to be instrumentally valuable and
so I would have to have a long
conversation to to figure out a way in
which I would be able to see the tree as
intrinsically valuable in the way that
self owners are no because it can't be a
self owner right now I could imagine
that suppose there's one human being
ever and there's also one you know other
sentient being that can also form
intentions and the where they could
interact in some way I could imagine
that they could develop a kind of
language between them and eventually
both become self owners that that seems
imaginable to me like higher order
primates or whales or dolphins or you
know so I think there are probably I'm
not a enough of a biologist to know
which things are I'm pretty sure trees
can't be because they can't form
intentions or beliefs or desires yeah
because I feel like in my questions I'm
here
the other ones I'm hearing an exercise
where we're all looking to try to like
challenge your presumption mmm but in
fact I think most villainous room have a
kind of like connected theory of
goodness whether it's the kind of like
social constructionist on the
sociological side bang we're studying
webs of people and recognize the
influence and the building systems work
so I'm trying to decide if you're
arguing against someone who is like know
there are atomistic individuals people
are billiard balls they pumping each
other and they are otherwise alone
and it's those people you're challenging
or you saying despite the fact that
we're actual connected and we all know
that there's a convenient fiction that's
sitting there that we kind of lean on
right and so you're trying to just like
take a fish right
yeah then okay so that's great so then
one question it's like maybe it's a
fiction and it's inconvenient fiction
that helps us organize things and we
could say it's problematic fiction we
could say maybe there'll be a better
fiction that would better understand
this but if I'm I do it makes sense to
me that there's a world where like I
both recognize that I am deeply tethered
to people through social relations and
language but I start out a way to like
heaven
come on tracks and that contract relies
on like I mean you're you know I have
stuff I can give you stuff that it
seriously great yeah wait so you don't
want to be like no I believe in
atomistic individuals you should
actually get to like is this a foolish
fiction for us to keep exacting yeah
yes that's exactly the point that that I
want to get to so the response is often
that well this is just an idealization
this atomistic individual just like you
know idealization Zinn physics or in
economics or whatever right and my
response to that is to say the value of
an ideal in that sense depends on its
youth right what does the theory give
you that that then that you get out of
making that idealization well in
political philosophy it gives you
libertarianism so it gives you a theory
that says you have no necessary
obligations to others that you don't
voluntary
contract for okay I think that's a real
problem I think that's a problem for the
world I think that we actually which
either some things by virtue of what we
are given without ever asking or
accepting voluntarily those things that
we inevitably have so much you know that
we we owe it to the you know pay it
forward or pay it back one or the other
we have an obligation to do that and so
the libertarian ideal that you actually
should have the tax list state you know
except for defense or something like
that is a mistake and it comes about as
a result of this ideal idealization so I
judge the value of an ideal based on
what you get out of it and I think you
get something not so good out of it so
it's question begging to say you know
despo but it's just an ideal well but it
gives me this bad outcome so let's
examine the ideal the ideals of fiction
here's the way in which it's a fiction
what would this give us alright so well
I'm gonna pass on by this because that
one that was just to say there are lots
of different causal origins of different
but let's move on to autonomy as an
ideal so if we are these self owners
what is an ideal way to be a self owner
well traditionally autonomy has been a
value in moral and political philosophy
for lotsa reason I could talk about
later but it's the basic idea of people
as self governors so it's an ideal of
freedom right I get to set my own I get
to set my own beliefs and desires and so
forth and nobody forces them upon me
autonomy has often has long been thought
of as a kind of individualistic notion
but more recently and I'm talking about
20 years now or something of political
and moral philosophy a notion of
relational autonomy has
been developed and particularly by
feminists and so that's the ideal of
autonomy that would go together with
this connected self ideal all right so
what is one of these that's particularly
appealing to me is the idea that a an
autonomous person is one who is who has
the ability to participate in collective
self government's so is not only a taker
of norms but also a giver
so can give and take argue about debate
disagree agree whatever about the norms
so on my view the connect itself could
not be a loan originator of norms got to
be others but autonomous connected
selves are both contributors to and
participants in the making and giving of
normative guidance and so now we get now
we get a little bit of payoff there's
not very much because I don't have a lot
of time but a little bit of payoff is
well the web of connection society
community networks ought to allow each
node within to become such a reciprocal
participant giver and Taker of norms in
in order to promote this kind of
relationship recive or as autonomy
enhancing so those would be two
opposites depending on whether they
enhance people's ability to be full
participants in this norm creation or
whether they for some people the merely
be takers and the others get to be both
givers and takers okay so so this is
just the basic difference between the
atomistic self owner and the connected
and so I'm gonna pass out them by two
because that's basically what
so what are these autonomy enhancing
communities or networks well they're the
ones that encourage reciprocity and one
way of doing that is by encouraging or
having norms of dignity and equality
because if if everybody has is has
dignity and equality they're authorized
by the normative framework itself to be
givers as well as takers of norms so now
I'm getting a little bit of political
payoff here to this and you know morally
speaking connected selves good connected
cells moral ones nourish autonomy in
each other by teaching and encouraging
autonomous capacities that is capacities
to debate civilly or you know without
violence and to talk about norms with
each other which of course we do all the
time right this is what most of our much
of our conversation is about it's about
normative facts and by discouraging
violence and other emotionally or
socially or psychologically damaging
practices which disable us from being
these full participants in the
reciprocity of norm giving and taking
and so basically this is a basic
principle I think and that is networks
or communities that are not autonomy
enhancing have no right to exist as such
and persons have moral obligations to
reform those or to help those who are
oppressed by them to fight to find
autonomy enhancing networks in which to
exist so you know now we can talk a
little bit about online communities and
the sort of reciprocity that should be
enabled by them so just like communities
in the material world online communities
can be either oppressive or an autonomy
enhancing right so if there are norms of
bullying and shutting people down and so
forth those are obviously not in time
enhancing you know there are some
networks some online sharing spaces that
provide the ability to have full
conversations without flaming and that
sort of thing but rather but but allow
for continuing threaded discussions in
ways that are more more productive let's
say and obviously spreading false news
is one way of psychologically damaging
people so and then just for privacy
rights so I think we you know you can we
have a duty not to harm others
that's not autonomy enhancing after all
and norms of trolling behavior or
creating false news that gaslights
persons or making defamatory false
claims about people and those kinds of
things those are kinds of privacy
violations and some of them they cause
harm and we we have a duty I think to
avoid doing things like harvesting
personal data without permission or
passing on data that's been legitimately
collected in one way but using it ways
that then lead to these kinds of harms
or that you know that that can lead to
non autonomy enhancing networks right
and so I would say we can derive the
idea that software develops developers
have a duty to avoid having their
products be used in such a way that they
harvest personal data without permission
or pass on data that's been legitimately
collected in various ways so yes
Jers having different new shoes right
yeah that's just because they want to
yeah abide by the minimal laws rather
than is that the case well Facebook is
infringing on the autonomy of Canadians
is is there an argument that could be
good so what my theory allows us to do
is to judge entire normative frameworks
right so what we could say is that it
turns out the North American normative
framework legal framework is not the
best normative framework the EU has a
better one right if I mean you could
make it in terms of this in Tonica
autonomy enhancement and the likelihood
of creating the false light false news
and and harvesting personal data I
didn't say much about why that's so bad
violations of privacy but but I could
talk some more about that but so this I
think is a framework that gives us
exactly the kind of ammunition we need
to argue that the whole framework of the
legal structure is inadequate at this
point right not that legal structures
are the only ways of creating normative
frameworks but they're pretty important
and it seems like if we if we have these
sharp disagreements like Facebook on one
side and you know I don't know others on
the other you know we're gonna have to
adjudicate that in a way probably that
uses a certain amount of
probably what's required yeah people
will inevitably become connected when
they meet each other I mean they're
going to find ways of communicating even
if it's not her knowing exactly the
language of each other so you use the
language maybe in a little bit of a
minimal sense but what I would say you
know in that there that a community that
say takes in another community refugee
community say of people who don't speak
the same language and ken is not going
to be very autonomy enhancing if it
doesn't help those individuals to
communicate with the rest of the the
community but I should also said that
there I think lots of autonomy enhancing
normative frameworks and so you could
have two different communities that have
very different norms well especially you
know aesthetic norms etiquette norms
moral norms still there could be some
differences in moral norms I think that
could both be autonomous and autonomy
enhancing and yet not exactly the same
okay
so when they come into conflict probably
some respect norms that need to come
into play in order to enhance the
autonomy of of both
but I do think that individuals need to
have the right to abandon one set of
norms and and and go to another
community if for if their autonomy is
not enhanced within a particular
community so once a cellphone are always
a self owner sort of so you don't have
to speak the language that you're you're
dropped into a new new country and you
don't speak their language you're still
a self owner but you're going to have to
probably to be an autonomous self owner
within this new community you're going
to have to learn some of their language
in order to be able to eat to
participant doing this questioning of
normative frameworks I'm struck by what
seems like privacy rights and I think
this pervades a lot of current policy of
course if we just can protect our
privacy or if we're able to own our own
data so there's still this adoption of a
kind of individualistic work and I'm
just wondering if we keep brought in the
social imaginary and think about not
just individuals but you know it's just
social rights collective rights is that
deserve well one thing is I think it's
important I don't know if this gets
there but it's it's really important to
see why publicity is so important to us
as well as privacy so that's a value
because without publicity our ability to
make public to each other what we think
and what we believe you we don't have a
normative web right so so publicity is
is is very valuable as is privacy and I
think privacy is valuable because again
each of us is a node each of us does
suffer an individual fate if you will
and can be individually picked out
for abuse or something like that so what
I think the connected self-ownership
ideal helps us to see is how important
it is to balance the needs of publicity
and the needs of privacy but maybe
you're right maybe that still doesn't
get beyond the individualism and as I
said I am ultimately a liberal just not
a libertarian and normative
individualism is something I embrace so
maybe I can't get totally over to the
communitarian side so let's see somebody
I'm seeing several problems if you try
to sort of put it out there so one is
that a lot of these terms that you're
using which I you know again that I love
like you know normative you know social
relations and all this the libertarian
is just now I'm gonna listen to any of
those concepts and secondly one thing
that we've learned about libertarians or
similar behavior especially in the last
election cycle from sociologists is that
their notion of group is very different
from what say me as a sociologist we
consider a group so like Harley hope
she'll just had this book on
you know Tea Party movement and the way
that this group sort of thinks about
who's their inner circle is very
different it's not everybody it's not
the entire web and the various groups on
the web it's their immediate circle you
know and that's the care group that they
would care about no more so how you know
again how would you make them think
about the web is normative web is this
larger community I'm third who's that
who's the subject that we're really
talking about here so we have all these
individuals that are on the web and you
know they're all many of them are
thinking you know I have libertarian
right so I can do what I want I can with
hate speech I you know I can you know
this is sort of my right but it's not
just individuals now we know this is you
know difficult thing is that the
trolling and the false news is now being
conducted by one BOTS right
oh we can't really talk to and number
two by these you know Canberra general
look good like like and Russian you know
what do you call them the trolling
organizations so it's it's these some
illicit organizations and it's these
tech designers and now it's like you
know Zuckerberg who like is you know
himself like you know aligned with these
groups who are doing these things so
this idea that there's a single sort of
you know libertarian purse that we have
to convince hmm right it's so difficult
yeah yeah yeah so philosophy is pretty
impotent there's no doubt about it it
that is what what I can say is you you
libertarian you have the wrong
metaphysics of the self na nananana
that's not very powerful in the world of
coercive agents who are willing to use
force to get what they want right I
agree
those who say well but I've got these
rights and I you know that's actually no
you know if that is supposed to have
some kind of moral grounding or some
rational grounding turns out you're
wrong but if you want to coerce me well
like I'm gonna have to bring force
against your force that's true so you
know philosophies ultimately impotent
against people who are willing to use
force against others
as for the bots though they're created
by actual human beings and I'm saying no
you have a duty not to create these
things having a duty you know that's I
am going to shun you if you don't stop
creating those BOTS I mean that's not a
very powerful position in in the world
of bad people but in the world of those
who are saying the right to say free
speech regardless of the consequences
for the community well no actually I'm
going to argue that you don't have this
kind of right that's completely
unbounded yeah so yeah it depends on
your the the amount of force that your
opponent's willing to apply
yeah I can see why it's a very powerful
anchor or grounding but I also wonder if
there are elements sort of implicit
associations sort of pull against what
you're trying to do in a connected side
yeah and if there are if there were
other groundings or metaphors yeah so
maybe too much disclosure I I was
assigned to do some kind of critique of
libertarianism and so I took up the self
ownership idea and then I said oh there
might be a different way of thinking
about it right but then the question is
why preserve the idea of self-ownership
and I can think of five reasons okay so
you know I think it retains this idea of
claim so ownership brings up with it
claim it preserves the idea that there
is this this node in the self that is a
primary moral importance the
individualism the normative
individualism I think comes with it but
it also because it's connected self
ownership it suggests that the creation
of cells is a collective endeavor
I think the ownership metaphor brings
some good things but I agree there are
some bad things too but it's just
investment and that we're paying forward
this that's what investment is that we
have an obligation to invest ourselves
in the project of this norm creation in
order to be really autonomous fully
fulfilled beings and then finally it's a
traditional liberal way so going back
really you can trace it back to at least
the 15th century a traditional way of
thinking about it and also we have a
compliment to somebody is to say oh
you're very self possessed right
it's a kind of confidence and so forth
that is supposedly admirable so there
are some good aspects to it but I admit
there might be it might come with so
much baggage that
it's not a good idea yes and just how I
mean I can see all the arguments there
and that makes sense within philosophy
is there room to make agency the shuttle
that that's connected and still allows
for some self determination but the self
can be yeah I I think absolutely that
the idea of agency doesn't necessarily
come with this idea of a claim a self
possession claim but certainly agencies
always a very important concept for
philosophers yeah we're a little over me